Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin Erdem Özer und auf dieser Station als Systemastätik.
Wie ist Ihr Name, Doktor? Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden. Ich bin etwas schwerhörig.
Können Sie nochmal wiederholen, Ihr Name?
Okay, ich bin Erdem Özer. Hören Sie mich gut?
Doktor Özer?
Ja, genau.
Alles klar. Was ist das für ein Name, Herr Özer? Doktor Özer?
Erdem Özer.
Wo kommen Sie her, Doktor?
Aus der Türkei.
Ah, das ist ein türkischer Name. Ich war auch schon mal in der Türkei, in Siede.
Ach so, wie?
Wann?
Oh, schon 20 Jahre her.
Sie haben Urlaub gemacht oder?
Urlaub, in Siede gemacht, ja. Das ist eine sehr heiße Siede.
Eine schöne Stadt, ja.
Ich würde auch gerne geben, aber ich...
Es sind ganz viele Deutsche in Siede.
Ja, viele Menschen gehen aus Deutschland.
Alle Deutschen machen das Siedemonstraal auf.
Ja, okay.
Gut, Herr Doktor.
Ich kann mich auch kurz vorstellen, mein Name ist Hildegard Knef.
Frau Hildegard?
Frau Hildegard Knef war so eine Frau.
Hildegard?
Hildegard.
Könnte Sie mir bitte Ihren Freund nach Namen ustabilieren?
Vorname ist Hildegard, schreibt sich H-I-L-D-E-G-A-R-D.
Hildegard.
Okay.
Mein Nachname ist Knef.
K-N-E-F Knef.
Machen wir mal.
Sie hatten nach meinem Alter gefragt, Herr Doktor.
Ja.
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
26. Juli 1953.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 m und ich wiege 74 Kilogramm.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich war Büroangestellte, also Sachbearbeiterin.
Aber ich bin in Rente.
Seit wann sind Sie in Rente?
Also, ungefähr 5, 6 Jahren.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwirrt wird, mein Mann ist verstorben.
Mein Mann, bei ihr.
Ja, danke schön.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder, die sind aber auch schon erwachsen.
Danke.
Frau Knef, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Welche Bescherung haben Sie im Moment?
Herr Doktor, ich habe Lungenkrebs,
wie Sie aus meinen Unterlagen entnehmen können.
Da ist jetzt im Februar dieses Jahres festgestellt worden.
Ich habe dann,
Prinzip,
eine Chemoemontherapie bekommen.
Ich habe dann Nebenwirkungen von der Chemoemontherapie.
Dann ist die Luft sehr schlecht geworden.
Herr Doktor hat gesagt, ich habe eine Autoimmunpneumonitis,
eine Autoimmunentzündung der Lunge,
die dann mit Kollison behandelt worden ist.
Ich war dann ungefähr 3, 4 Wochen im Krankenhaus gewesen,
wegen einer starken Luftnot-Lungenentzündung.
Ich habe immer noch Luftnot, wie Sie sehen können,
brauchen Sauerstoff.
Sauerstoff langzeitbar an Blunk.
Aber das ist jetzt in den letzten Wochen etwas besser geworden.
Aber ich brauche immer noch Sauerstoff.
Der Onkologe hatte mich jetzt geschickt,
dass wir die Chemoemontherapie weiterführen können.
Ich habe aber seit 2 Tagen hinten am Po
einen Ausschlag bekommen.
Okay.
Wann genau wurde Lunge-Entzündung
als Diagnose festgestellt?
Und danach mussten Sie ungefähr 3 Wochen
im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Also die Lungenkreis wurde festgestellt im Februar 2022.
Dann habe ich einmal eine Kombination
Chemoemontherapie bekommen.
Einmal nur.
Dann habe ich diese Nebenwirkung gehabt
von dieser Autoimmun-Lungenentzündung.
Deswegen habe ich eine Langzeit-Korrelation bekommen.
Ich habe immer noch Korrelationen hochdosiert.
Ich muss sich einnehmen.
Das muss langsam ausgeschlichten,
wie hat der Doktor gesagt?
Ich nehme zuerst ein.
Im März.
Ungefähr 3-4 Wochen war ich im Krankenhaus.
Und dann nach dieser Behandlung haben Sie weitergegangen.
Mit dieser Chemoemontherapie?
Nein.
Der Doktor hat gesagt, der Situation war zu kritisch.
Er hat gesagt, ich soll mich ein bisschen erholen.
Und dann will er noch mal versuchen,
nur Chemoemontherapie zu machen, ohne Immuntherapie.
Vor 2 Tagen hatten Sie Ausschlag,
besonders im Po.
Am Po, ja.
Sind diese Beschwerden löstlich aufgetreten?
Innerhalb von den Tagen war es sehr stark juckend.
Durch Katzen habe ich auch offene Stellen.
Es sind Wunden am Po.
Bis diese Schitäle politisch werden,
müssen Sie immer wieder.
Mit Blutig momentan.
Sie haben nur Yukreis und Ausschlag.
Äußere dieser Beschwerden haben Sie.
Es gibt noch etwas beispielsweise Schmerzen.
Es tut auch weh.
Wenn ich mich draufsetze, tut das weh.
An diesem Stellen.
Das sind richtige Wunden, die Bluten.
Vor 2 Tagen haben Sie etwas eingeromen.
Was denken Sie als Ausschlaufer?
Für diesen Ausschlag gibt es viele Medikamente.
Ich nehme viele Medikamente ein,
seitdem ich aus dem Pragen aus entlassen worden bin.
Ich habe jetzt kein neues Medikament genommen.
Hab ich Medikamentalist dabei?
Ja, kann ich ihn vorlesen, wenn Sie möchten.
Ja, gerne.
Ich nehme das Methylprednisone.
Mittlerweile ist es diese Woche auf 40 mg reduziert worden.
Das wird um 10 mg reduziert.
Wie viel Milligramm?
50 mg.
Und davor war 70 mg.
Und davor noch höher.
Jetzt hat einer das 40 mg Methylprednisone.
Das ist eine Tablette?
Ja, eine.
Eine morgens.
Dann habe ich wegen meiner Schildtröte und der Funktion L-Teroxin 75 mg.
Wegen der Korrosionbehandlung habe ich dann auch noch Vitamin D,
den Kristall 1000 Einheiten, die ich nehme.
Und 45 mg.
Und einmal pro Tag?
Einmal pro Tag, ja.
Und Vitamin D?
Ja.
Und morgens wieder?
Ja, morgens.
Dann habe ich noch Folsore, Folsan, 0,4 mg.
Das ist wegen der Chemotherapie.
0,4 mg?
Ja, 0,4 mg.
Und einmal pro Tag?
Richtig, einmal pro Tag, nehme ich mit Paxia.
Dann habe ich den Magenschutz, Pandopazol, 40 mg.
Und morgens oder abends?
Das nehme ich abends momentan.
Dann habe ich meine Blutdruck-Tablette, Vasa Coa, 80 mg.
Was war das?
Vasa Coa, das ist eine Blutdruck-Tablette.
Vasa Coa.
Das ist eine halbe Tablette von den 80 mg.
Morgens.
Dann habe ich noch für meine Lungenerkrankung Foster.
Foster.
Foster, ja.
Das ist für die Lungen-COPD-Erkrankung.
Ein Hubmorgens.
Und dann ist nur noch verschrieben worden,
weil ich jetzt diese Langzeit-Kollusion-Bahnlung mache.
Kor-Trim-Forte, das nehme ich dreimal die Woche ein.
Kor-Trim, Moksatso.
Kor-Trim-Forte.
Kor-Trim.
Und wie viel Millikran?
Das ist, glaube ich, 960 mg.
Davon nehme ich dann morgens und abends zwei Tabletten,
aber nur dreimal die Woche.
Das soll wegen dieser Kollisionbehandlung als Profilachse,
damit ich keine Infektionen bekommen, hat der Doktor gesagt.
Kor-Trim.
Kor-Trim, ja.
Oder Backtrim.
Ah, ja, okay.
Und dann habe ich noch Zetrezinis genommen wegen Juckreiz.
Das waren die Medikamente.
Ich weiß noch, ob Sie alles mitschreiben konnten, der Doktor.
Okay.
Und gefällt neuen Medikamente, nehmen Sie ein, ja?
Oh, ich habe nicht gezählt.
Wenn Sie mitgezählt haben, dann wird es so sein.
Okay, alles klar.
Sie haben gleichzeitig angefangen, diese Medikamente, ja?
Seit wann genau nehmen Sie diese Medikamente ungefähr?
Also dieses Kor-T-Zone seit März.
Und diese ganzen Mitamin D.
Und diese Parmtoprazol und diese Kor-Trim auch seit D.
Aber ich hatte vorher schon diese Schilddrösen-Tablette
früher schon bekommen.
Die Foster hatte ich auch schon früher wegen der Lungen der Erkrankung.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Oder zum ersten Mal haben Sie bekommen, ja?
Zum ersten Mal diese Beschwerden.
Früher hatte ich so etwas noch nie gehabt.
Und zum ersten Mal kamen Sie zu einem Arztaphyaya
oder zuerst ging es die zum Hausarzt.
Also wegen dieser Beschwerden bin ich jetzt zum ersten Mal bei Ihnen.
Da weist du noch nicht beim Hausarzt.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Schweizer?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Überalkite oder Erbüreschen?
Momentan nicht, Herr Doktor, nein.
Ist Ihnen Schwindelik oder Schwarzfordern angehen?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, aber ich bewege mich auch nicht viel.
Ich kann wegen meiner Luftnoten nicht so viel machen.
Ich habe da ein Sauerstoff gerät und kann nicht so viel laufen
Wie ist die Appetit?
War eigentlich jetzt normal, kann ich sagen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit umgewohnt, ab oder zu genommen?
Jetzt, seit dem Kortison habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen zugunahm,
in den letzten zwei Monaten vielleicht.
Könnten Sie das genauer sagen?
Also vielleicht so ein, zwei Kilo, würde ich sagen,
vielleicht 72, auf 74.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Ja, habe ich.
Können Sie nicht gut schlafen?
Ja, also auch mit dem Sauerstoff in der Nase,
kann ich mehr oder nur nicht so gut schlafen wie früher.
Deswegen fühlen Sie sich tagsüber schläfig?
Ich bin insgesamt sehr schwach, ja.
Also ob es an der Schlaflosigkeit liegt, weiß ich nicht, könnte sein.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich müde, krasslos, abgeschlagen?
Ja, aber seit Diagnose der Krankheit, ja.
Sind Sie willenlos, teilnahmlos und so weiter?
Ja, kann man insgesamt freudlos.
Ja, ist nicht mal wie früher, ist richtig.
Meine Psyche ist auch schlechter geworden,
als früher durch die Diagnose Lungenkrebs.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Schutulgang oder Wassalasen?
Bisher aktuell nicht, noch nicht.
Okay, Sie sind da seit in den Wechseljahren?
Mit 68 Jahren, ein bisschen spät, würde ich sagen.
Und besuchen Sie regelmäßig einen Frauenarzt?
Also da war ich jetzt schon ein paar Jahre nicht mehr, muss ich sagen.
Und beim Lestern war alles in Ordnung?
War in Ordnung, da ist auch Mammografie gemacht worden,
war alles okay, war fast 200-300 Jahren gewesen, glaube ich.
Da gab es keine Probleme.
Okay, Sie leiden an Schilddrüsenunterfunktionen
und Magengeschwür.
Nein, Magengeschwür habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay, wegen dieser Medikamente nehmen Sie Pantoprosolier.
Ja.
Okay.
Und COPD haben Sie auch.
Also, ich habe noch etwas.
Also ich hatte eine Schenkelheizfaktur,
die operiert wurde auf der linken Seite, nach Sturz.
Und ich habe als Kind, also ich habe Hüftatrose,
beidseits gehabt schon.
Und das ist aber, ich habe wohl ein Hüftdisplasi,
als Kind wohl gehabt, ist mir gesagt worden.
Also jetzt habe ich Hüftatrose,
als Kind, als Arthrose gehabt, beidseits.
Hüftatrose haben Sie und sind Sie schon deswegen operiert worden?
Das war dann, das war dann ein Unfall gewesen, da bin ich gestürzt,
ab der linken Seite ist da eine Prothese drin.
Aber, okay, Prothese, ja.
Rechts habe ich immer noch Arthrose, ja.
Okay, wann war das genau?
Oh, das war vor.
Der Unfall?
2-3 Jahre ungefähr.
Okay.
Bluthochdruck, Blutzu-Kakrankeit,
Bluthochdruck, ja.
Blutzucker ist nichts erhöht gewesen, ja.
Und gegen Bluthochter nehmen Sie etwas ein?
Das war Sarkoa, das Medikament, das habe ich ingemacht.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Okay, größer Wagen auf dem Hof beds дома?
rą Franken Castro?
Mussten Sie auch operiert werden?
Sonst habe ich keine Operation.
Ich überlege gerade noch, als junges Mädchen bin ich nicht mal
blind am operieren und aber schon sehr lange her.
Okay, sind Sie total geimpft gegen die bisher gewischten
Krankungen?
Also ich bin gegen Covid geimpft, gegen Influencer und auch gegen Lungenentzündung habe ich Impfung bekommen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie die Kinder, die ich meine, bei ihren Eltern oder Geschwistern oder Kinder?
Meine Eltern sind schon tot, weil es nicht ob es da Krankheiten gab. Meine Kinder sind so weit gesund, die haben keine besonderen Krankheiten.
Okay, rauf mal Sie.
Ich habe geraucht, ich habe aufgehört letztes Jahr im November.
Gut, und wie viel Jahre hatten Sie geraucht und gefahren?
Ich habe mit 16 Jahren angefangen und das ist aktuell so.
Wie viel Zigarette pro Tag eine Packung?
Ja, war es sich auch mal mehr gewesen, anderthalb, aber so im Schnitt, im Durchschnitt würde ich sagen eine Packung Zigaretten, eine Schachtenzigaretten.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Eigentlich fast nie, ganz, ganz selten.
Okay, eine Routinefrage, haben Sie Erfahrung mit den Drogen gemacht?
Nein, habe ich keine Erfahrung gemacht.
Okay, Frau Knief, das waren meine Fragen. Meine Meinung nach habe ich alle wichtige Informationen erhalten.
Deswegen würde ich fragen, haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas zu fliegen?
Also ich will nur wissen, ob das etwas Ernstes ist.
Okay.
Was denken Sie mit meinem Hautausschlag am Gesäß, am Steißbein?
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich einen Verdacht darauf, dass Sie einen Nebenwirkung von einem Medikament haben.
Aber zuerst würde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Okay, Sie haben jetzt körperlich untersucht, die Patienten hat Gluteal, rechts, aber auch in der Mitte, über dem Steißbein hat sie ein externe Themen, so ein bisschen bolös, auch pusselös.
Manche Stellen sind wundaufgegrattet Gluten und das geht praktisch von Gluteal bis zum Steißbein runter.
Hauptsächlich rechts, aber ein bisschen auch in der Mitte, da links, auch ein bisschen da links.
Es gibt auch Bläschen, die teilweise jetzt aufgegrattet sind, das ist jetzt so ein Wund, große Wundestellen, aber hat auch Flecken und auch bläschenartige Veränderungen.
Du Bulley und Fusteln.
Und Settilism hat auch nicht gerufen.
Also es hat die Hygieneit ein bisschen abgemildert, aber nicht so gut, es hat immer noch Hygieneits und Schmerzen auch.
Aber gut, was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose, Doktor?
Sie haben das als Nein-Medikament, sagen Sie, oder?
Ja, ich würde so sagen, aber hier gibt es viele Medikamente, deswegen soll ich auf diese Medikamente mich konzentrieren.
Aber Arzneimittel exantem und der Langzeithochdosis-Styroidtherapie muss man sagen, ne?
Ja.
Das hat mehrere Wochen, also mehr als acht Wochen hat sie hochdosiert, Cordison.
Normalerweise wird man als Arzneimittel exantem, wenn es schlimm ist, mit Kollison behandeln, normalerweise.
Absolut, absolut, normalerweise.
Gut.
Okay, gehen auf.
Das ist eine andere Idee, was sein könnte.
Ist nicht ganz typisch, muss ich sagen.
Okay, aber ich habe normalerweise die Medikamente für Hygieneitstherapie gefragt, aber ich habe keine Notiz gemacht.
Ich habe die Chemotherapie nicht gesagt, nee.
Was waren diese Medikamente für Hygieneitstherapie?
Carboplatin, Pimetrexate und Immuntherapie Pembrolizumab.
Das war im Februar, Februar 2020, also vor drei Monaten.
Ja, nur einmal, ja.
Einmal, ja.
Also kann sein, aber es ist unwahrscheinlich.
Unwahrscheinlich.
Undenkrebs.
Was für eine Idee haben Sie noch, da gibt es jemanden aus den Zuhörern, der noch eine differenzialen Diagnose-Idee haben kann.
Also es kann als Arzneimittel exantem sein, richtig?
Was gibt es aber noch für eine Möglichkeit?
Ja, die Patienten haben Missofilbebewung, deswegen sieht es wahrscheinlich den Ganzen tak.
Von Taßaysduruk, Taßaysduruk, Duruk, Gechüür.
Ja, aber wie nennt man das?
Wie nennt man das im Fachbegriff?
Duruk, Gechüür, Taftegrit.
Der Kubitis, der Kubitis Ulcerose.
Also ist das nicht eine Analphisur?
Analphisur?
Ja.
Ich habe jetzt nicht untersucht gehabt, aber zumindest weil es jetzt...
Kein Problem beim Schutulgang?
Kein was?
Kein Problem beim Schutulgang.
Das ist nicht berichtet, nein.
Das exantem war jetzt nicht direkt Anal, sondern eher so ein bisschen weiter Peri-Anal bis Gluteal.
Bis über Ur-Sakrum-Region.
Hauptsache rechtzeitig, ein bisschen über die Mittellinne hinaus muss man ehrlich sagen.
Und natürlich Probleme bei den Bulutungsparameter, weil die Patienten Krebs habe.
Das ist ja bei solchen Patienten, können manchmal ab Bulutungen...
Wobei es jetzt keine Anticoagulation hat, also es hat keine Anticoagulationen.
Krebs heißt immer, denke ich, so.
Krebs, oder Vergnungstörungen machen ist richtig, ja.
Okay.
Aber Trombos, Hütten und so was, alles normal war, ihr kann es sagen.
Okay, aber was ist das, was ist das, also ich...
RGPL oder Herpes?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, genau.
Also Langzeitssteroidtherapie, was ist das?
Immunsoversionen, gell?
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja.
Und an welche denken Sie da, hauptsächlich?
An welche Viren?
Herpes?
Herpes Simplex, aber dann gibt es noch mal ein anderes Virus, das auch
Herpes macht, so nennt man das.
Herpes Zoster.
Ja, Herpes Zoster, ja.
Ja, Zoner, Götelrose, ja.
Deutschland ist es nicht so, Deutschland ist Götelrose, ja.
Götelrose.
Also, das ist der Verdacht bei der Patientin, ja, Götelrose.
Auch wenn es jetzt nicht typisch ist, normalerweise ist ja hier
Matermatom bezogen, aber kann selten sein, auch mal in dem Bereich sein, ja.
Ja, man erwartet generell an den Liebpen, für Herpes, aber, ja, natürlich.
Das ist, das ist Herpes Simplex, labialis, das hat, es ist ein anderer Virus, gell?
Herpes Zoster ist ja vielleicht ein großes hervorgerufen.
Ja, natürlich.
Welcher Virus ist Herpes Zoster?
Herpes Zoster.
Ist nicht Herpes Simplex.
Ja, Varicella, ja.
Varicella, Torsterviren, genau, Varicella, Windpocken, ja, auf Deutsch, Windpocken.
Ja, genau.
Okay, gut.
Alles klar, dann würde ich sagen, stellen Sie Oberatz kurz vor, in dem Fall, ha?
Ja, natürlich gerne.
Okay, guten Tag Herr Oberast.
Guten Tag.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin, nämlich Hildegard Knief, aufgenommen.
Ich würde diese Patientin mit Ihnen besprechen, hätten Sie dafür kurze Zeit?
Ja, gerne, bitte schön.
Okay, Frau Knief sei 8 und 60 Jahre alt und 1,75 Meter groß, 4 und 70 kg.
Seit 6 Jahren sei sie in Rente und früher habe sie als Bearbeiterin gearbeitet im Büro.
Sie sei derzeit verwirrt und habe sie bei Kinder.
Im Februar wurde bei dieser Patientin Bronchial Parsinum als Diagnose gestellt.
Und nach dieser Diagnose haben sie einmal Chemotherapie und Immenterapie eingenommen.
Nach dieser Therapie kam es zur Nebenwirkung gekommen.
Und wegen der neuen, musste der erst die Behandlung stoppen wegen Autoimmunipinomenie.
Und wegen der Autumimmunipinomenie musste sie ungefähr 3 Wochen im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Und dabei habe sie Cortison mit Hochdosiert.
Ja, Hochdosiert, Cortison, eingenommen.
Das wurde im März passiert.
Seit 2 Tagen habe sie exantiert, besonders im Bereich des Posts, besonders auf der rechten Seite.
Und sie haben auch Prioritis, deswegen mussten sie kratzen bis diese Stelle blutig werden.
Und an diesen Stellen haben sie auch schmissen.
Und dann mit viele Medikamente nehmen diese Patienten wegen einiger Krankheiten.
Ich würde alle Medikamente sagen, mit den Präthnisolon.
Sagen Sie mir die wichtigsten, die neuen Medikamente.
Okay.
Mit dem Präthnisolon, der Seite, hat sie 7 mg, die Tablette einmal pro Tag.
Und wegen der Hypatroise, der Seite, die langen Jahre Auto-Troxin, 7 mg,
Vitamin D, Folsoire, Pantoprosol, wegen dieser Medikamente.
Und gegen Arterelle Hypertoni, Walzacoa, halbe Tablette und Foster wegen COPD,
nimmt sie ein.
Und als Proflaxie nehmen sie Kordirin, 80 mg, 3 Mal pro Woche ein.
Und gegen Prioritis nehmen sie Cetrisim.
Und früher haben sie solche Beschwerden nie gehabt.
Und dann der getrative Anamnesis ist unauffällig bis ins Omni,
in Somni Kraftlosigkeit und Lethargie.
Und wegen der Krankheit ist sie ein bisschen depressive.
Und sie klagt überall Aboliv und Apathie.
Und sie bewegt sich nicht so viel.
Und in letzen Wochen haben sie 1-2 kg zu genomen.
Seit 2-3 Jahren besucht sie keinen Frauenast.
Aber beim letzten Mal war alles noch nötig.
Sie hat das so gesagt.
Und wegen Chemurfraktur mussten sie operiert werden.
Und derzeit haben sie Proteise.
Und als sie Kind war, wurde auch Appendectomy durchgeführt bei ihr.
Im Status sei auch vollständig in der Familie,
in der Familienanamnesis, ja, familiäre Anamnesis,
in der Anamnesis ist auffällig.
Im November hatte sie aufgehört zu rauchen.
Aber früher hat sie viel geraucht und Gefahr.
50 Jahre, ein bis ein anderthalb Pausungen pro Tag.
Kein Alkohol und keine Drogen.
Das war so.
Und die Ausschläge ist Lebulutik.
Und sie haben auch bemerkt,
Belschule, ja.
Hab ich nicht ganz verstanden, dass?
Sie haben auch Belschule.
Belschen.
Belschen bemerkt.
Aufgrund der Anamnesis habe ich einen Verdacht auf eine Infektion mit herpes Sona.
Herpes Soster.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose können natürlich
Nebenwirkungen von diesen Medikamenten befragt kommen.
Und dann, ja, sie haben keine Bewegung,
das wir in der Dunkelheit auch über
über
Decubitus ulcerose nachdenken.
Decubitus, genau, das war so,
Decubitus profilaxida in dem Fall, ja, damit sie keinen bekommt.
Also, an Differenzialdiagnose haben sie gesagt,
Arzneimittel externteem, also Arzneimittel bedingt.
Was auch noch sein kann, dass sie durch den Juckreiz vielleicht
Verletzung gesetzt hat und die durch die Immunseprogression
vielleicht auch eine Bakterianfektion begünstigt haben können.
Also eine Yatrygen-Hautverletzung mit sekundärer Bakterienfektion
kann auch sein, ja.
Absolut, ja, sie habe kein Fieber, aber natürlich sollen wir das auch denken.
Was würden Sie, also wenn es jetzt nicht ganz klassisch wie ein
Herpes Soster aussieht, was würden Sie machen an Untersuchung,
damit Sie wissen, ob es Herpes Soster ist,
gibt es eine Möglichkeit festzustellen, ob es Herpes Soster ist.
Ja, so erst soll ich die Körperdicht untersuchen.
Da haben Sie gemacht.
Das Bild ist nicht so ganz typisch, also normalerweise
ist es immer so ein Dermatom hier.
Es war hier nicht ganz typisch, aber Sie haben trotzdem
Verdacht auf Herpes Soster.
Was können Sie diagnostisch noch machen, um das vielleicht
so ein bisschen zu unterstützen, die Diagnose bedacht?
Nein, mit Ultraschall können Sie das nicht verstellen.
Was wollen Sie mit Ultraschall gucken?
Ja, hier gibt es die Gewerbe,
sollen wir auch kontrollieren.
Mit Ultraschall? Bei Herpes Soster?
Nein, für Differentialdiagnose, meinst ich.
Welch?
Aber?
Also auf einer wunden Hauptstelle, Ultraschall
ist meist nicht so gut.
Ja, in den Muskeln wahrscheinlich, aber nicht für Herpes Soster.
Da bringt nichts.
Herpes Soster ist eine klinische Diagnose.
Wenn es mal etwas untypisch sein sollte,
kann man noch ein paar andere Sachen machen.
Zum Beispiel Labortests, kennen Sie die?
Ja, das kann man machen, aber im Hinblick auf Herpes Soster,
war jetzt ja eben Soster-Virus.
Im Immunglobulin? Ja, im Immunglobulin und G.
Na, könnte hinwas geben, ist nicht so hilfreich manchmal,
aber können Sie machen? Was kann man noch machen,
außer Immunglobulin gucken?
Alles schon.
Jetzt selten gemacht, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
man braucht es oft nichts, weil es oft ganz klar ist.
Aber in selten Fällen, die Franzisalldögnose da ist,
kann man aus diesen Messickeln, aus dem Bläschen,
Abstrich machen, eine PCR machen.
Auf einer seltenen Toaster könnte man.
Aber ganz selten, ich hab das nicht.
Kommt fast nie vor, aber im unzupositionswerten Patient
muss man manchmal machen, damit man auch keine falsche Therapie macht.
Normalerweise, wenn ich mich richten kann,
dann ist es so, dass bei den Patienten,
die Krebs haben, ist das regelmäßige,
es gibt regelmäßige Untersuchungen gegen Systeme,
wie wir das so weit gehen.
Also nicht bei allen Krebspatienten,
aber gerade bei den hematologischen Patienten
mit dem protokoll,
vor allen Dingen bei den Patienten mit Transplantationen,
mit dem dem hematologen, oder auch mit dem dosmalen machen.
Kann auch mal sein.
Also bei Patienten mit soliden Tumor,
bei der normalen Chemotherapie,
wird das nicht regelmäßig gemacht.
Ja, genau, nicht regelmäßig.
Aber gut, das haben Sie Diagnose gestellt,
wie behandeln Sie das?
Ich würde ja, ja, gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten,
als Creme, als Salve können wir auch Asylglovia,
oder ja, nie, ganz Asylglovia, so weiter geben.
Also Asylglovia ist sozusagen Standardtherapie bei uns.
Ja, oder als Tablierte können wir auch das geben.
Ja, machen, genau.
Was ist die Komplikation bei Herbst-Toster?
Was ist da gefürchtet oder was da an Problemen?
Ist das gefährlich normalerweise, Herbst-Toster?
Normalerweise nicht so viel, aber ins Gehirn oder?
Gehirn, genau, kann mal Meninko Instaverdienst machen,
im Mund zu pülen mit den Patienten, richtig?
Ja.
Und sonst, was aber jetzt bei Patienten,
die jetzt nicht so stark immun zu pülen mit den Patienten sind,
das kann da Problem sein im Verlauf nach so einer Infektion,
oder bei einer Infektion mit Verrützern,
Reinfektion oder Reaktivierung muss man ja sagen, ja.
Superinfektion.
Ja, aber schon mal, was von der Postzostaneuralgie gehört?
Postzostaneuralgie, also Sie haben manchmal sehr lange
und komplizierte Schmerzprobleme, ja.
Ja, deswegen soll man die...
Platten, Platten, Perioden, muss ich sagen.
Ja, die können sozusagen so eine Postzostaneuralgie entwickeln,
das kann hartnäckig über viele Monate auch manchmal Jahre gehen,
dass ich erst abwollt schon abgehalten bin, ja.
Was kann man gegen Herbst-Toster machen sonst, profilaktisch?
Kennen Sie was?
Kann man Profilaxen machen?
Macht man das?
Ja, wenn impft man gegen Herbst-Toster?
Normalerweise...
Kinder bekommen diese?
Ja, Kinder werden gegen, mit allem im Stock gegen Windpocken geimpft, ja, richtig.
Aber jetzt erwachsen sie nicht.
Die schon mal Windpocken hatten,
haben ja meistens alle erwachsen Windpocken gehabt schon früher, ja.
Ist ja der gleiche Virus, Varezellen-Virus ist das, ja.
Den impft man, impft man jeden.
Also in Deutschland gibt es ja eine ständige Impfkommission, STIKO,
die empfiehlt eine Impfung für Herbst- oder gegen Herbst-Toster
bei allen über 60, also auch gesunde,
und bei über 50-Jährigen bei Patienten mit chronischen Erkrankungen
und Immunsepresso.
Er wird empfohlen.
Ja, diese Patienten, ja.
Wenn Patienten mal Gürtelrose gehabt hat,
dann empfiehlt man den trotzdem impfen oder nicht impfen?
Eine gute Frage. Normalerweise...
diese Krankheit bleibt...
Lebenslang im Körper, ja.
Dann reaktiviert werden.
Aber trotzdem soll man...
Also man impft auch Patienten, die schon mal Zoster gehabt haben,
wenn sie vor allen Dingen diese Gruppe kommen von chronischen Erkrankungen
oder immunsupremänten Patienten,
auch wenn sie Zoster schon mal hatten,
können die wieder 2-3 Mal auch bekommen,
und Zoster kann sich wieder reaktivieren.
Und mit der Impfung wird die Wahrscheinlichkeit geringer,
dass sie reaktiviert wird
und vor allem nicht diese Komplikation,
die das Post-Toster-Noralgie bekommen.
Deswegen impft man auch Patienten, die schon mal herbst-Toster hatten.
Wie impft man denn gegen Zoster, ist es zufällig?
Und gerade mit welchem Impfstoff?
Mit welchem Todimpfstoff oder lebendem Impfstoff, wissen Sie das?
Es gibt beides, aber man impft heutzutage im Todimpfstoff
und im Abstand von 2 Dosen,
erst Impfung und dann die 2. Impfung nach 2-3 Monaten nochmal.
2-6 Monaten ungefähr.
Ab des Zoster.
Bei allen Patienten über 60 empfohlen von der Impfbemission.
Ist das eine gleiche Impfung wie die Windpocken?
Der Virus ist der gleiche, aber der Todimpfstoff ist ein anderer.
Man kann nicht mit dem Impfstoff gegen Zoster die Kinder impfen.
Gegen Windpocken sollte man nicht.
Da gibt es einen anderen Impfstoff.
Der Zoster-Impfstoff ist ein anderer,
als der Impfstoff, der bei Kindern wegen Windpocken gegeben wird.
Danke.
Es hat eine andere Konstellation.
Ich weiß nicht, dass es in Antigeno ist.
Okay, das war für heute der Fall.
Vielen Dank, Herr Dezade.